all right what do you got vic a rate my
joke guys i have a headache i have i
have the headaches of an nba player but
not the skills i have kids a baby
uh baby mama and backed up child support
but when it comes to tax time i feel
like an nfl quarterback every year i get
intercepted
hey all right premise is strong
yeah i like the first part yeah um about
like how you have all the problems of an
nba player but you don't have
the skills of the money yeah
it's kind of like well those are the
important parts
yeah right it's like
hmm i had a bit of my my opener in my
out to lunch brush was i'm i think i'm
autistic with just the bad parts i got
none of the smarts and i can't count the
toothpicks on the floor but
i'm a you know whatever give you a lousy
hug now he'll give you a bad hug yeah
i'm distant and i give you a better yeah
he needs that and he's like the right
word like what what are you so you have
all these
you have all the stuff that you don't
want yeah you're like man i uh
i should be more specific when i wish i
could be like an nba player
right yeah i like i meant jump and
dribble
right right i didn't mean uh
yeah forget to pull out yeah i did not
have a real job what is with people not
being able to pull out what's up with
the pull-out game
not only that what's up with people just
never wearing condoms and
someone who just knocks up and you're
like what do you do like i wear condoms
they work i gotta tell die yeah i mean i
know broken condoms happen but like what
are we doing here yeah and it's fun to
jizz places you know like you should you
should be looking forward to that yeah
the bus the aquarium laces
well you got this it's like an added
thing the stomach hits the face peter's
just pointed to my hand
that too
you know if you're you no one else oh
yeah and then i throw it in your face
like i'm spiderman
with great power comes great
responsibility
suck it vulture
i think i'm housekeeping i'm sorry yeah
yeah yeah there's something there yeah
it's close
it's it's it's
tough because he switches over to nfl
i'm like maybe you should start with
athlete
that way you don't have to go nba to nfl
yeah i don't know if the nfl thing adds
a lot right now i think the first part
is something though yeah i agree
all right